Je t'aime beaucoup c'est pas la question
On a passé des très bons moments toi et moi              mais ça ne marchera jamais
Parce que je suis ta mère et que je t'aime
[Cris]
Qu'est-ce qu'il t'arrive? Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé?
J'ai tué quelqu'un je crois
Hein? Quoi? T'as tué qui?
Gilles, un copain
Ah oui c'est le monsieur qui s'habille en clown? C'est ça?
Les gens vont remarquer qu'il a disparu
-Je vais appeler les flics                                                             -Non
SAM!
Fais pas le con Sam! Lache un prout
-ALLO?                                                                                         -Oui allo passez moi le conseil des fantômes s'il vous plait
Tu te rends compte de ce que tu me demandes là?
-Oui passez moi le conseil des fantômes s'il vous plait      -OK
On a du boulot
Non on a plus de pipi
Tu peux me rappeler ton prénom s'il te plait?
BATMAN!
-Pardon?-J'ai une cape-c'est qui?
-J'ai un grappin-c'est qui?-J'ai une batmobile-TA GUEULE!
Ca va mec?
Arrête avec ça
T'es sérieux?
Roberto je vous dérange pas? J'espère au moins que vous parlez de cul
Ouais l'anus!
Yannick ? Qu'est-ce que c'est, ça?
J'aimerais bien mourir
Arrête avec ça ! T'as du charisme
-C'est une blague?-Mais évidemment que c'est une blague
CONNARD!
-Tu préfères peut-être crever ici?-Ouais
D'accord Yannick
Eh ben il est mort
[Pleurs]
Tu pleurniches alors qu'il y'a des enfants qui meurent de faim en Afrique?
(En pleurant] Il est parti
Hé regarde Romuald !
Wouf! Wouf!
-On dirait mon père  -Parce que?  -Parce que tu bandes plus
(Applaudissement)
T'es un connard!
STOOOOP
Si on se fait la guerre on s'en sortira jamais
-C'est pas idiot -Je confirme -Ouais
Que la force soit avec toi
Ta gueule !.. Pardon
T'es un grand malade
On t'encule
Ben non!
Enc*lé Fils de p*te de ta mère!
Ok...
Je vais t'aider
-Eh ben merci t'es trop chou-Ah non pas du tout non
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
Est-ce que tu préfères un doigt...
Non non
D'accord
-Ouais j'ai mes règles ouais-Merde!
-Je croyais que tu m'aimais-Ben bof
T'es un porc!
-Est-ce que tu veux bien qu'on reste amis ? -Non
-Allez au revoir-Non
-Vous avez du temps à perdre avec ces simagrées?-Oui
-Oui -Non -Oui -Non -Oui -Nan -Oui -Nan...
Arrêtez putain
Va chier
Vous avez vu comment elle m'a traité monsieur
Niveau bagarre comment vous vous en sortez?
-C'est pas là où je voulais aller-Moi non plus
Alors Merci Vous êtes 2 millions d'abonnés et c'est vraiment énorme
Merci! Merci! Merci ...
Merci tout le monde!
Je bande un peu...